hey youtubers is Charlie so they just
posted the Oscar nominee so I thought
it'd be fun to do a reaction video
generally I don't think of the Oscars
too seriously I don't take it too
seriously I think of it more as a
reminder for all the awesome movies that
I did not see during the year like the
whole list of nominees is just judging
me for not having seen them there are a
lot of movies that got nominated so I'll
mention a couple really important ones
that I think you should check out in
case you missed them too we should say
upfront though the Oscars all award
shows in general complete [ __ ]
they're not designed as much to
recognize talent as they are to sell
television advertising so if a movie you
really like didn't get nominated don't
freak out the way people vote on the
nominees is ridiculous there's actually
a really good Mental Floss article that
describes it in great detail like in
excruciating detail so I'll add a link
in the description there's also this
episode of South Park the funnybot
episode that beautifully describes the
way you should feel about award shows
it's all about the speech that funnybot
has at the end they defeat him with the
logic problem by giving him a comedy
award in recognition of his achievement
it's such a perfect speech I'll just
I'll play the audio right here an
acknowledgment of all you do in the
pursuit of human so yeah that's the
perfect way to think about award shows
in your head it's not just Comedy Awards
it's all word shows in general so my big
reactions totally not surprised about
Birdman and Michael Keaton being at the
top of the mentions Birdman Best Picture
Michael Keaton best actor I know I
didn't do a review for him but it's one
of the best small movies of the year
I think guardians of the galaxy was
probably my favorite big movie I try not
to lump everything together whenever I
get super judgy about movies and TV just
just because most things are made for
very specific audiences and award shows
are made to be very broad I think the
biggest bummer is that the lego movie
totally got snubbed one of the directors
Phil Lord posted this picture on Twitter
probably my favorite reaction this is
probably like the best Oscars reaction
there was some backlash over some of
being snubbed in the Best Actor category
David Oyelowo played Martin Luther King
jr. he has his amazing performance he's
actually on Star Wars rebels he plays
this character this is probably who a
lot of you know him as people are
that the Oscars have been whitewashed I
feel like that's a problem that's
endemic to Hollywood films in general so
it's not a new problem this happens all
the time so here's like the Cliff's
Notes for movies that you really have to
see that are gonna be talked about a lot
at the Oscars first off is Birdman
really funny really dark it totally
makes fun of Michael Keaton's Batman
films they even did this parody ad that
really laid into the original trailer
for Batman Forever
in a world of darkness in a time of
chaos
the only hope to save a city
is a hero who flies in the face of evil
moon
1992 is the year
of the bird
man that's what I'm talking about
riggan Thomson in Birdman returns
that was the movie that made Michael
Keaton leave the Batman franchise he saw
the script and was like this blows peace
I'm out of here see a Foxcatcher another
super intense super dark story with
Channing Tatum Steve Carell and the Hulk
Mark Ruffalo Steve Carell is up for Best
Actor and Mark Ruffalo's up for Best
Supporting Actor
I always like checking out the Avengers
whenever they do really small
interesting movies so if you ever
wondered why there's so much talk about
them getting tired of playing big
characters like white Mark Ruffalo
doesn't talk about the Hulk all the time
I mean people ask him about the Hulk all
the time
but usually he likes to talk about his
other stuff it's mostly because the
small stuff they do allows them way more
creative freedom they get a lot more
authorship every once in a while like
everything comes together in a really
amazing way and you get a bird man or a
Foxcatcher those are two extreme
examples of like brilliance small movies
that ended up being is fun is a big
comic book movie so moving down the list
I'm assuming everyone saw the lego movie
like two or three times maybe even four
then bought the DVD so we're good on
that one
if you miss Ben Affleck and David
Fincher's gone girl that's that's
totally okay it's a really weird movie
people are gonna be talking about it a
lot but if you want a good barometer for
Ben Affleck in Batman vs Superman I
think a better movie of his to see is
probably the town which he starred in
with Hawkeye that's actually the movie
that earned Jeremy Renard the role of
Hawkeye in Avengers by the way David
Fincher and Ben Affleck are actually
reteaming up this year like the same
production team to do a new version of
Alfred Hitchcock's strangers on a train
so I'm more excited about that than I am
about gone girl there were 10 of great
animated films that were nominated
Studio Ghibli's last big film Princess
Kaguya that's something you absolutely
have to check out just on principle I
mean it's a good movie - it's an amazing
movie just looking at the sales figures
I'm assuming everybody also saw how to
train your dragon - and big hero 6 I'm
behind on boxtrolls I actually still
haven't seen that yet - but you guys
need to see that everyone totally saw
guardians of the galaxy so no need to
worry about that it was one of the true
comic book movies that got nominated and
it was in the make up and visit x
categories comic book movies in general
usually only win awards for technical
achievements even Christopher Nolan got
snubbed all the time for his Batman
films critically the ones that do stand
out are the ones that look and feel very
different very unique that's actually
one of the reasons why I like guardians
of the galaxy more than Winter Soldier
plus I have a bias for space opera which
I'm totally will
to admit here's my big question for you
guys you know scanning the list of all
the nominees which of your favorite
movies actually made the list i'll
actually i'll add a link to my tumblr
with like a full breakdown in case you
haven't seen the list of nominees yet
i'm not planning on doing any big oscar
videos but i will consider it so if you
guys really want some oscar stuff i'll
try to do some whenever they actually do
the awards i am working on Game of
Thrones and Star Wars for tomorrow so
new Game of Thrones new Star Wars coming
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
know everyone's talking about Suicide
Squad this morning too because Tom Hardy
dropped out he was playing the Rick
Flagg character I'm sure somewhere in
the distance Jake Gyllenhaal's phone is
ringing off the hook
David Ayer doing Suicide Squad he also
directed end of watch which Jake
Gyllenhaal was the star of so I'm
assuming that he is on David Ayer short
list and when you look at him he looks
like a good stand-in for Tom Hardy
anyway physically right now in case you
haven't seen it you can click here for
my Avengers Q&A from yesterday I just
answer who some of those mystery
characters are and you can click here to
start getting ready for air on the flash
which come back next week so thanks so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you tomorrow
you